The FSB
in Russia is pretty much like what
the KGB used to be.
It's a feared security service.
So Vladimir Putin once let you know,
Melissa Bell
just caught up with two FSB defectors
Her view was of Moscow from the inside,
a life of privilege and access,
including an FSB vehicle as a doctor
working for Russia's
federal security service.
The powerful FSB.
I'm Maria Dmitrieva,
the Today is October 12th
and I filmed this video in the plane
from Moscow.
A Cold War style defection
booking a flight
to France
before anyone suspected she might go
to the border.
I'm now in the French territory, complete
with photographs
as well as work
contracts, patient records and references
to prove her identity
to French authorities.
She also brought documents
she thought the West
might be interested in.
Your previous love for them.
But it is long overdue.
I brought photos, audio
and video recordings,
which confirms
that the majority of the Russian army
is against some of the policies
of the current leaders.
At my own peril and risk,
I was able to smuggle
my phone into the FSB building twice
and was able to make some records
She also brought recordings
of conversations
with senior officials,
she says, to hand to French intelligence
currency as she sought political asylum.
Dmitrieva is one of a flood of senior
Russians, from soldiers
to Wagner, mercenaries and FSB employees
now arriving in Europe.
So many that Putin promised in December
to promptly identify traitors, spies
and saboteurs.
Even as Europe has been expelling
senior Russians.
600 in 2022, including 400 spies,
according to the head
of the British intelligence agency MI5.
---
But in an exclusive interview with CNN.
Former senior FSB Lieutenant
Emran Navruzbekov
of, says there are plenty of active
agents left in that room.
Back Off
comes from a family
of security service agents.
Many of his relatives now under arrest
in his native Dagestan.
Before defecting,
he worked for the FSB in Poland.
Now he's seeking asylum there,
especially the FSB.
The role of the FSB
since the beginning of the war.
Would they want to end the war quickly
but failed?
No.
In the FSB, it's every man for himself.
Everyone wants to escape from Russia.
Every second FSB
officer wants to run away.
Now, already
they understand that
Russia will never win this war.
Now he is not.
Of course, I'm afraid
you know how they work.
History says that in
any case, I will be killed.
Vladimir Osechkin says he's helped
at least
20 senior
Russian insiders escape
since the war in Ukraine began.
The exiled Russian
human rights
activist is on Moscow's
list of wanted
criminals and insists
on meeting in a public place
In September, French police
opened an investigation
into a possible assassination
attempt at his home.
I saw my wife and children
who spent more than 30 minutes
on the floor
and the children was very scared.
And my wife,
like look like Mazur to protect them
because it's a risk of the shoots
in this moment.
It was very difficult.
Here is one first a search.
Osechkin says it's his help to those fleeing
and the documents they bring
that make him a target,
like the images
he shows us on his computer.
Of what he says
are Russian
surveillance radar positions
aimed at Europe dating back to 2017
given to him as such.
Cohen says
by a three star general now in exile.
Putin.
Why should you want to kill me?
I'm so very scared.
There is a lot of people
who now work in the Putin system,
but they want to find a way to
work together with the West,
with Ukraine, with Europe,
with the United States,
and to stop Putin.
What is such can leaves us.
It's with some of the policemen
who since
September ensure
his security day and night.
Maria,
like many of the Russians
arriving, has no such protection
and little money left.
But she agreed to speak to us
hoping for a better future in the West
and most of all joins us now.
I mean, it's
just extraordinary what they're doing.
How do Western security services
make sure that some of these defectors
are not intelligence
agents sent by the Kremlin
with either false information
or to try to get in
with other defectors or
anti-Russia groups
Well, the fact is, Anderson,
they simply can't.
And there have been
so many examples across Europe,
but also in other countries
in neighboring
Russia of people who fled, claiming
to be
seeking genuine asylum,
who turned out to be
still working for the FSB.
In fact,
Vladimir said
that you show there in that report.
I was tricked by one
only a few months ago, a man
claiming to need his help,
who turned out
to have been sent by Moscow
simply to try and get closer to him.
And because of that.
What you're seeing
is more and more of those neighboring
countries and European countries
simply deciding
that they're not going to be giving visas
to those trying to flee.
Now, that leaves
many Russians
who are trying to get out
in a very difficult position.
Now, you might say,
why have any sympathy for
the people who've been working
inside the regime of Vladimir Putin?
But that suspicion
also affects
so many other Russians, Russians
who come from much lower down the ladder.
Journalists, for instance,
who've tried to get out
since the war began
simply because their lives
are going to get so much harder
as a result of it.
And what they find
themselves is in positions
where they managed.
If they managed to get to Europe,
they have no more access
to their families
who have been left behind and might
well be in danger,
no access to their bank accounts.
Facing that deep seated
suspicion, about who they are
and what they're doing
and why they may be in Europe
with very little prospect
of getting asylum.
And of course, the fear
that they'll simply
be sent back to a country
where they will not be treated tenderly
and less well. Appreciate it.
Fascinating report. Thank you.